welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name
is hisham azuz welcome back to another
episode of the 15 minutes with a mental
series
where we're interviewing some of the
mentors from inside the community
in line with the launch of the
recruitment mentors community
and we're asking the mentors seven
questions in
15 minutes delight to be joined by
michael today but for those
that may not know you if you could
introduce yourself and then we'll get
into that
thanks um yeah good to good to see you
again um
yeah so my name is michael judkins i am
a senior manager at
a marketing and digital and e-commerce
recruitment company in london called
research and i head up a couple of parts
of the
the business one focused on consumer
marketing
roles and then the other is a specialist
recruitment function um responsible for
recruiting some of the channel specific
roles across marketing and
it's funny class amazing first question
what was your biggest challenge in 2020
how did you overcome it and what did you
learn from it
uh yeah i i i got asked this recently
i've got two
um so i don't know if i'm going to be
greedy and that's fine it's okay
so they link to be you know they need to
be fair so i think
biggest fear when i went you know when
everything happened was
how am i going to manage my team
remotely um
i'm very much a well i've always felt
like i'm very much a
face-to-face you know kind of manager i
get more from
my team if i'm face to face um because
i've typically worked one day a week at
home
anyway so i always knew on those days i
didn't really feel like i was
getting as much from maybe the team as i
would have liked if i'd been face to
face
um and yeah i i guess i i feared that
you know
the the change in communication style
and and the fact that you know
it wasn't just that across the desk
would would have a negative impact on
on you know how we would um you know and
how it would we would work and i think
you know that for me was you know the
number one
kind of you know challenge and i i guess
you know
actually what it taught me was that
there was an opportunity to talk openly
with the team about how we communicate
around certain areas and actually what i
do think since then is that we are
better at communicating because we've
had to adapt and work in an environment
where it isn't just
instantly over the desk so what you get
i think
is more meaningful conversations when
you do speak and you're actually into
the detail more
because you're having you have less
opportunity to have those kind of
smaller conversations you know just here
and there so
you know on one hand i do miss them
because it's probably more
instant and reactive to the situation or
the problem that might be at hand
on the other hand i feel like i get more
detail when i do catch up
and therefore we can dive into things
and what that also then has done is
given them the responsibility to be able
to go away and
deal with those problems themselves as
opposed to just relying on me because
i'm sat opposite
them or yeah i'm two meters away or
three meters away from them you know
whatever it may be
so actually that you know they've had to
step up and up skill because they've had
to deal with certain situations if they
can't get hold of me because i'm on
another zoom call or you know or or you
know or something so it
yeah that that was probably the biggest
challenge and that's i guess
the outcome of what's happened um and
then tying into that i think is then how
how to motivate the team you know when
you know i think you know we've seen a
lot about this recently as
you know the first um you know the first
lockdown you know was met with this kind
of wave of like enthusiasm
collectiveness you know
togetherness across the business and the
team you know the second one was you
know pre-christmas i didn't think you
know
actually i think there was you know some
hope etcetera and then this time round
you know you know it obviously i i don't
know about you know what your
conversations you've had but i feel like
it's been harder at times for a lot of
people um
and actually motivating them when you
yourself are going through some of those
challenges
can be quite a hard thing to do because
we're all experiencing this it's not you
know
everyone's impacted um and actually
that you know i know that's i know
that's kind of started this year but
it's obviously part of last year is
is a massive challenge for me it's like
right you know you're not maybe not
feeling up for it today but how do i get
myself in the right
mindset and frame of mind for my team
meeting so that you know
actually you know they they feel this
energy and positivity and i think it's a
balance between
you know actually explaining how you
feel and that you're in that with them
and yeah
you know you're not some robot who isn't
impacted by it so showing some empathy
and showing some kind of
you know that you are impacted by the
situation but also trying to have the
right mindset to say
that this is what i'm going to try and
do about it and this is what i'm going
to do today and setting clear goals and
and you know just communicating with
them about how you're going to do it so
that they feel that they can manage that
too
um but it's quite hard to motivate when
you're when you might be feeling you
know
the same as them yeah amazing nah thank
you so much for sharing that michael
that
that was great so on that point then i
guess it'd be interesting to hear this
from you so
what working from home tip could you
share with your
with other recruiters that has had a
massive impact on your productivity
oh um
uh well i guess yeah i think
for me for i guess in terms of like
productivity for myself because i
haven't been in the office i've actually
been able to
spend more time focusing on
on maybe my own activities as opposed to
always having to deal with maybe some of
the teams you know issues or challenges
um so one thing i did say and then links
back to that
point around the communication is you
know setting a dedicated time to talk so
whether i'd be in the morning
and then actually getting on with what
you know i need to do whether that's
sourcing for a job or trying to win some
business or
you know maybe i'm interviewing you know
someone actually
that's then my dedicated task and my
slot to do that and therefore i don't
have the other interferences that you
might well get
when in the office so i guess my tip is
plan ahead plan your day
make sure you've got time for yourself
but also then time if you are a manager
for a team
but make sure you're breaking your day
down into times where you're trying to
focus on that task and people around you
know
that that is what you're doing at that
time and they know when to speak to you
or interact with you so that you can
then focus on that because it's quite
easy to get distracted in this job and
then
you you lose sight of what you were
doing in the first place
um so just trying to be organized i
think yeah great
so on the topic of business then what
what has been the most effective way for
you to win business in the last 12
months then
um i think it's been a i think it's been
a combination of things
um leveraging long-standing
relationships which you know was
was the first point to call um yeah i
think
we have as a business traditionally
focused on that and how we want a lot of
our work has been
based on who you know previous um
relationships and actually you know
providing a good service and doing a
good job for them and then getting a
recommendation and referral and that's
how we typically build a business
in the first few years um because we
were a bit of an unknown in our market
um you know people weren't aware of us
so we had to come with
you know some recommendations and
testimonials and referrals of good
business because you know why were they
going to give us a chance over our
competitors who they've worked with or
heard of for 10 15 20 years
um i think we're now at that point where
actually our brand does hold a bit of
weight when we
approach people and people know who we
are so we don't have to
you know we've got other options
available but you know because of last
year and because of what happened and
because people did stop recruiting you
had to kind of rely on those
relationships
um and um yeah make time for people
you know really build i think it was
like building trust with people that you
know
you can help them in however way they
you know they want
and that might be recruitment it might
be some advice um
and then i think just providing that
extra level of customer service
and just going above and beyond what you
would typically do in in the job
was why i feel like we were able to
um yeah win win some more work and pick
up some more work towards the back end
of the year because we just really
you know we really really tried to
deliver on everything we could and go
above and beyond
because we knew it was tough and we knew
that other people out there might so
just providing that extra level of
customer service
um for us so you know saw a fair few
results
um and then the other things that we did
were you know
you know some of the kind of branding
stuff and and you know trying to get the
team and the guys to talk more and share
more insight through you know
linkedin and social channels and then
holding webinars and events and and
actually adding some value in a
completely different way
and we've never we've done a little bit
of that but we've never really done it
consistently
and we did um you know five or six
webinars towards the back end of last
year i hosted one and
you know um got a panel together of
people some people who i
worked with others who i just kind of
come into contact with and it's really
good because you know they're now people
that i could
i could quite happily pick up the phone
to and talk to whereas six months ago if
i'd called them
it might have been a bit you know there
might have been some like why you know
why you're calling whereas actually now
you know they've hopefully gained some
value from being on this webinar or this
topic and people have attended it and
it's just a nice little touch point for
people i think something different than
you know i want to help you recruit for
a job yeah no i love that amazing
so what habit or hobby did you start
in 2020 that you're going to continue in
2021
well i didn't start but yeah we were
talking about it earlier
um yeah i mean i i just i just i just
got back into running
um so yeah if any of my team or business
are listening to this
um later on they'll laugh always talking
about strava
and uh yeah times and stuff but um
yeah for me that was a big one um and i
i was so
i think i was inspired by everyone else
getting into doing you know
um physical you know physical outdoor
activity as well but in particular
running because it's always been me
talking about it i've always been a
runner but
i think no one's ever really got the uh
fascination with
with how you know the benefits of it not
just you know physically but actually
mentally
um yeah for me was a real way to clear
my head and what has obviously been a
really tough year it was just some time
to myself where i could clear my mind
and have a think
you know listen to a podcast or some
music and just you know completely zone
out um
and yeah i just again i i think i just i
fell in love with it again like i had
done it
maybe previously but yeah it's good to
see so many people doing it as well
so i want to know then which do you
think is better
the first coffee in the morning or
the first pint post work on a friday
oh it's got to be the pine yeah
yeah it's yeah that's right yeah yeah um
i mean i do like coffee
i mean for me i'm i'm coffee all day
long but most people said pints so far
that's good i'm sorry i feel bad um
i'm not i'm no lash legend these days
but um yeah i would probably say the
beer at the end of the week is
yeah i think that's a hard one it's a
hard one to
give up yeah nice fair right so
next one is a slightly different it's a
scenario and i want to hear how you'd
approach it so
a particular business who's been sort of
a target client of yours
for over a year long period of time and
during that time there's been several
touch points
from them engaging with some of your
content maybe uh one of them might have
attended one of your webinars you might
have sent them some emails
and through your candidate network you
managed to get one of the hiring
managers
contact details at this company so you
call that person they pick up they
answer they say hello who is this
and i just want to hear how you would uh
approach that conversation and that
first
interaction uh yeah
fair enough um i think
you know you know kind of it can depend
on the situation but
i guess for me personally it would be to
try and build some form of
of credibility or um you know establish
some form of relationship early on
so whether that's talk about the people
that we know um you know uh
you know together or mutually you know
connected to or whether that's talk
about something that we might have in
common or some of the tough ones we've
had
um and just approach it you know very
much you know
with how i can help them or you know
what
what their situation is you know they
might be looking for a job for example
and
you know they are i would certainly
spend the first part of that call
focusing on them and their search and
not even talk about
necessarily anything to do with with me
trying to recruit for them
um but along the way i'd probably try
and give some relevant examples about
work where we've previously helped
similar clients or
oh actually you know such and such i
help them you know worth asking them
um and then as part of my questioning
around their situation perhaps if they
are looking you get into team and
understanding what they've done to get
to that point
you can then you know just ask an honest
question you know an open question about
you know how they you know typically
would go about recruitment and
you know start that yeah i think
sometimes it's you can overthink those
questions but actually just asking that
question is
is the hardest is the hardest thing for
people to do and not enough people do it
um you know try and skirt around the
question trying cleverly about how i can
you know win this piece of work you know
by asking it as long as you build you
know as long as you build up some form
of credibility and
and hopefully by being engaging and
knowledgeable about your industry or
sector
by asking that question you shouldn't
get a negative response
i often find if you get a negative
response or closed or really you know
quite like why have you asked that you
know that you know that's not you know
that's not right or that's not what this
call is about then that's typically
because
we haven't done enough in the start to
build up
yeah we just haven't done enough to make
sure they know why um but hopefully if
you've done that bit right
that question yeah you might not
necessarily want but you probably get an
answer that you can then work with again
and then i guess it's about in your mind
working out when that next touch point
is and when that next conversation is
um yeah i don't you know i would never
expect to go into that call
um picking up and picking up a job i
would expect to go into that call
um knowing that i'm going to do my best
to you know give them a good impression
of me
so that if i pick up the phone again and
again and again hopefully over time i'll
win that work
and that's if i go into it like that
rather than i'm going to go into just
winning a job
then i'm not then defeated if i get off
that call and i don't pick up that job
in that first call
um great because i think it's easy to be
like right i'm gonna pick up the job
and yeah great that's obviously what you
want but it doesn't always work like
that it might take a bit it might take a
little bit longer
you've got to be prepared for that i
think nah brilliant final question
so just wanting to imagine the sort of
you're speaking to a recruiter who has
like yeah you were just sharing with me
before this with your team and stuff so
you're speaking to a recruiter that has
set goals for 2021
they've written them down they're
feeling motivated they're feeling pumped
they're going to have a better year than
they did in 2020.
what would your advice be to that person
that you think would
help them have the best possible chance
of achieving the goals that they've set
themselves
um yeah i kind of uh liking this to
maybe running because when i set my
goals i'm like
right what do i want to be at the end of
the year and actually how am i going to
get there
um i typically break that like break
break them down
you know you might have a goal for the
whole of the year
but that's a long way yeah 12 months in
this job is a long this long time so
break it down so make sure you have some
smaller goals
some short-term objectives and some
medium and some long-term objectives
so that you can celebrate stuff along
the way the other thing is that i think
if you've got the smaller medium and
you know objectives actually they're
stepping stones towards the long-term
objective and the long-term goal
so you're focusing on stuff that will
help you get to that long-term goal
and it just kind of realigns you and
focuses you like where do i need to be
in you know at the end of q1 where do i
need to be at the end of you know half
year
and then at least you're then on track
or you can see if you're on track
um you know to get to that end goal so
i'd certainly break it down
um the other thing i would then say is
like expect
things to change and happen along the
way and yeah you know by breaking it
down i guess that's less of a you know
it you can realign and maybe you might
need to kind of you know change that
goal slightly
because something's happened you know
like last year something happened we had
to realign what we were doing
you know actually be okay with that and
expect things to change and and accept
those changes in a positive way that
they're like right i can do something
about that and change your mindset
um and then yeah just i guess trust that
you know trust the process to get you
there and believe in it and follow that
love that michael that was 15 minutes of
a mentor thank you so much
thank you mate very good to see you
again